that was a super important moment those
are the two things that hold you back
the two things that hold everybody back
ask so many of you are just not asking
you the fear of rejection or the
laziness of the execution is stopping
people from winning happiness I think
that is a very very fun it is one of
those two things Marcus I'm telling you
right now if you actually have a product
and you actually spend ten hours a day
and I love when people are like ten
hours back I was running a very large
wine retail business and when Twitter
came out I went pop committed all-in and
I was spending ten hours a day
I built my entire brand from that
ecosystem
it's unbelievable what ten hours a day
of asking 850 chef a day on Instagram a
hundred and nine chefs will take a photo
with your olive oil 39 moms that have a
lot of other moms that give it up we'll
take a photo with your olive oil and
it's just the work and the asking
that was a super important moment those
are the two things that hold you back
the two things that hold everybody back
that's it
you